[Music]
things are not going well for the black
panther walk on the forever crew back in
august jewelry actress leticia wright
suffered an injury during a stunt on set
after a short-term stay in hospital the
28 year old took some time off to fully
recover it seems that her injuries are
more severe than initially thought and
thus the team has now come to a point
where shooting without the character who
is essential to the film would no longer
make sense consequently the responsible
parties have decided to stop filming for
this year and to resume in january 2022.
whether and how exactly this unplanned
break will also affect the release date
on november 11th 2022 is still unclear
after almost four months of shooting the
cast and crew of ant-man and the wasp
quantomania wrapped up their final take
last tuesday this was announced via
twitter by director peyton reed who also
directed the two previous films what he
left out were of course further details
about the plot of the third handman
movie all that is known as is usual of
many other marvel films is who is
starring in the movie the cast is at
least a reason to be excited because you
can look forward to many familiar faces
among them are paul rudd evangeline
liddy michael douglas michelle pfeiffer
michael pena and many more we also know
that jonathan magers has been cast in as
yet unknown role here many are
speculating on kang the conqueror what
reid also shared with the twitter
community was an impressive artwork by
mark james hiblin on it you can see hope
van dyne aka the wasp on the helmet of
her partner ant-man ant-man and the wasp
quantomania will be released in theaters
on july 28 2023
the matrix resurrections is without
questions while the most anticipated
movies of the remaining year barely a
month before its release warner brothers
decided to publish further material on
its blockbuster on twitter you can enjoy
a few posters each of which highlights
one of the main characters these posters
are definitely well made but at the same
time they do not reveal anything new
about the largely unknown story we do
know at least that the plot takes place
about 20 years after the events of
matrix revolutions and will once again
revolve around thomas anderson the
protagonists of the prequels much to the
joy of many fans we will see many actors
from the original trilogy again
including carrie and moss jenna pinkett
smith and keanu reeds also joining the
cast are jessica henwick neil patrick
harris yaya abdul madin ii and christina
ricci among others moreover the matrix
resurrections will be directed once
again by lana wachowski who along with
her sister is considered to be the
franchise's creator david mitchell who
co-drafted the script with wokkowski and
alexander hammon is full of praise of
the film in an interview with the greek
magazine in tovima the screenwriter
expressed that the movie is truly a
beautiful and weird creation he also
stressed that he could not reveal
anything more specific about the plot
however he added that it is definitely
not supposed to be another sequel but
something independent we are definitely
excited to look forward to the release
on december 22nd 2021
in the world of video games the mass
effect franchise has been one of the
best action role playing games on the
market for many years in addition to the
freedom of choice on the game players
are especially captivated by the space
atmosphere all of which is of course
filled with countless lovable characters
amazon now seems to want to use this
great popularity for its own series as a
report from deadlines states according
to them the company is currently in
negotiations with bioware and publisher
ea and there are very large sums of
money involved this matches the rumors
from the beginning of the year when it
was claimed that the witcher actor henry
cavill is taking part in the upcoming
mass effect project in case the rumors
turned out to be true and cat was indeed
starring in a mass effect series he
would naturally be in line for the role
of commander shepard the game's
protagonist either way it would come as
a big surprise after all a movie
adaption of the mass effect series was
already under discussion 10 years ago to
no avail whether the deal between the
right holders of mass effect and amazon
will actually come to fruition cannot be
predicted at the moment however we will
keep you up to date
the series arcane which has only been
completely accessible on netflix since a
couple of days is becoming a huge
success for the streaming service
netflix already announced the second
season this week and at the same time
stated that it is already in production
the joint project the ride games on
netflix is based on the hit game league
of legends and is about the ever
escalating turmoil between the two
cities of buildover and zone which are
located in the center of runeterra
piltero is known as the city of progress
and is in utopian paradise for signs
while next to it lies the city of zan
which is considered to be a darker but
also significantly freer version of its
adjacent city netflix didn't want to
reveal too many details about the second
season yet however it is certain that
haley steinfeld ella purnell katie long
and kevin alejandro will return as voice
actors of course we will notify you once
a release date for the second season is
confirmed
after wonder woman 1984 was rather flop
than a hit it was unclear for a long
time as to how the wonder woman
franchise should proceed wonder woman 3
was indeed confirmed almost a year ago
but in the meantime it did not seem as
if the production was making any
noticeable progress in early november
leading actress gallagher.com framed
once again that work on this script was
still underway as reported by the west
side the hashtag show the first details
about this story have already been
leaked by a trustworthy sauce it is said
that as tyria played by linda carter who
appeared in the end credited scene of
wonder woman 1984 will be featured again
she and the female protagonist must find
a man named aryan as his parents are
from both atlantis and themiscara and
thus he would have the gift of unifying
both realms as the story unfolds wonder
woman is then expected to team up with
aquaman to neutralize the madden aryan
in the current version of the script the
dc superhero blue beetle who will even
get his own solo movie is also believed
to play a role what are your thoughts on
the rumors surrounding wonder woman 3 do
you think the appearance of blue beatle
and aquaman would be realistic or do you
feel it is still way too early to
speculate feel free to tell us in the
comments
in the united states it has already been
out since november 10th while in other
parts of the world it will still take a
while until the movie is released we are
talking about paramount's new family
comedy clifford the big red dog which is
delighted viewers all over the world
with its sweet story or will at least
certainly do so in the near future in
fact clifford the big red dog is the
most streamed movie on paramount plus
today grossing more than 35 million us
dollars in the u.s thus far originally
based on the 1963 children's book of the
same name by norman bridwell the story
was then chosen to be adapted into an
animated series in the early 2000s on
wednesday paramount then surprisingly
announced that they are already working
on a sequel to the story of emily and
her growing duck delivered more detailed
information is not available as of yet
so it is also unclear whether the
paramount film will once again be shown
in both theaters as well as on the
company's own streaming service or
whether it will only be accessible on
paramount plus
well there you go those were our news
for this week if you want to dive deeper
into a possible sequel to the disney hit
movie zootopia alias zootropolis we
recommend a latest original from last
sunday you can also watch the first 5
minutes of jurassic world dominion on
our channel so don't miss this exclusive
movie clip
so
[Music]
huh
[Music]